Hello everyone, I'm Sam from the Free Wings flight school and today we're going to look together at the topic of materials.
It's a topic you've maybe already looked at a bit in the theory book or have already worked through theory questions, and there are quite a lot of technical terms, foreign words involved.
These are things you have to memorise a bit on the one hand, but today we'll try to put a bit of a face on the whole thing, so you have a context here and it becomes easier to learn.
What we're going to look at today is to first see what aircraft types there are, so you get a background here, where there are different paragliders, where you can also do different things with them, from here an acro paraglider to a school wing.
Why a paraglider is built the way it is at all — we'll look at the material side, we'll look at the harness, we'll look at reserve parachutes and we'll look at the materials for these specifically.
We'll look specifically also at the paraglider line, because it's quite important to know a bit how the whole thing behaves.
If we look at the paraglider categories, we have on one hand the school wing — that's the picture at the very top left corner, the white-red one — and we already see that's a simply built wing; it's not insanely highly stretched, rather it appears relatively compact.
And the big difference between a school wing and a competition wing,
the way it's beaten in the middle, is that the wing isn't so highly stretched, rather it appears relatively compact.
What we see here in the middle of the Fatterli, ultimately, is that the wing bobs along, that it's safe.
There safety is absolutely the most important thing. Performance isn't so important.
Subcategorised like the competition wing, it's the exact opposite.
There performance is important and safety is dialled down a bit.
Because there it's already demanded of the pilot that he can do a lot and can handle it.
Then there are many other subcategories.
We have for example in the right corner here a very special model
that has no lower surface, only an upper surface.
Here of course there's experimentation and even
this flight part is specially made
for hike-and-fly, so you have a very
small package with very little volume
and above all little weight.
And then the opposite,
which are built very robustly,
where weight also plays no role.
That's the acro wing, which you see here
in white-blue, which is made
so that you can fly manoeuvres with the
wing where the
most extreme g-forces, most extreme loads
act on the wing, but
the material holds, because
it's built that way, really strongly
constructed. And
there are also categories of
speed gliders, where you fly around with skis
and very small little wings.
That's ultimately
also a form of paragliding.
However a different category,
which we won't go into exactly now.
Paragliding as a whole
is also classified
into various
categories. We have A, B,
C and D. And with the
A wing we talk about the school wing.
That means, as it says here, that
passive safety is very high.
Ultimately the idea is actually that if
any disturbance happens on the school wing
and the pilot just lets go,
that the wing returns to independent
straight flight.
That would actually be the wish that every school wing
should fulfil.
Every designer making a wing
tries to get as close
to that as possible. And we are
today in a range where we can today say,
we fly the wings very, very safely
and nevertheless also already have
relatively good performance.
Performance, as a little mental aid,
we always talk about
glide performance. That means, if we
for example launch from 1000 metres
in calm air and just fly out into the valley,
we maybe get
8 kilometres with a school wing.
With a competition wing we're
nowadays at about 12 kilometres.
So that's already a difference, but 8 kilometres
is also already very, very good, when we
compare that just a few years ago
we were at 6 or 7.5 kilometres and now
we're rather at 8 kilometres.
Then it goes on with a B,
which is the intermediate wing,
on which most pilots probably fly.
Because that's a bit of what
you go to after the school wing, when you've already done a few flights —
I'm talking here of rather a few hundred
flights that you've hopefully done on the school wing —
to the B wing, which also still has
quite good passive safety,
but also already a bit of performance
and the pilot also has to already know a bit
what he's doing, respectively also react quickly
to a disturbance.
And that even more so with the D wing,
if we really go far up the wing scale,
that's definitely the case.
There it's demanded of the pilot that he reacts immediately,
that he no longer has to think about what he's doing
when he enters such a situation,
rather then he also has to react intuitively,
without having to think first
about what's actually going on with the wing.
How does a wing even
get such an A, B, C or D?
That's called the certification seal.
And the certification seal is now
actually the EN standard
that you encounter.
It's valid worldwide, except in Germany.
In Germany they're still on LTF,
which is the former DHV certification seal.
That's an absolute detail, not important.
But we have to know that German pilots
only fly with LTF-certified gear.
And otherwise worldwide
the EN certification seal applies.
What's done there?
On the one hand the wing is
loaded firmly with a shock load.
stress-loaded.
That's nothing other than the wing
being attached to a vehicle with a long rope
attached.
There's a pre-determined breaking point built in,
which then tears.
Afterwards the wing is examined,
to see if it has damage.
If the test was successful,
the wing is clamped in again.
The car now drives off continuously,
accelerating more and more,
until the wing that's hanging behind
is loaded to 8G.
8G is the absolute minimum.
Today's paraglider constructions
tend to go beyond that.
We're rather at 12 or even 16G.
If we take the acro wing,
we're surely rather at 16G.
There too it's checked afterwards.
Nothing has broken.
All components are still
as they should be.
An overall impression is made
and everything is logged.
The line strength is also tested.
Are they also as
the manufacturer specified?
A knot test follows.
The manufacturer has to do this in advance
and prove that his lines,
which he has built in here,
hold up and that the right thread
was used.
All of this is recorded in a
certification report.
Then you move on to the flight test.
The flight test is first very general.
What are the brake travels?
On a competition wing
the brake travels are rather shortened.
There we talk about 0 to 30 cm.
On a school wing
it's rather from 0 to 50 cm.
That can be a relatively long travel.
That's looked at.
Afterwards the manoeuvres are flown.
24 manoeuvres are flown with this wing.
Of these, 90 individual points are
then awarded.
That's an A wing.
If it has 90 A, it's an A wing.
If it has B, it tends to be a B wing.
And so all the points are awarded.
The whole thing is a bit difficult
with the paraglider,
because there's no measuring procedure for it.
That means it's ultimately
in the eye of the beholder.
It's an expert who's down below.
And the test pilot in the air
who judges that the manoeuvre
is an A wing or a B wing.
The whole thing is set up so that
every manoeuvre can be flown five times.
And once it falls into the category
that you want,
then it counts.
That means it can be four times a B wing
and once an A wing.
Then you know with which manoeuvre it's an A wing.
That's always somewhat criticised,
especially by the flight schools.
It would be nicer
if there were a majority.
For example three times in the manoeuvre
in the category.
Then it would be a bit more meaningful.
But also so important,
the wings that we have,
in the end it's indispensable
that you get advice at flight schools,
from flight instructors.
Because they know the wings best
and also know if it ever has a quirk.
Which however very rarely happens.
We have the whole thing well in hand today
and there are very good wings on the market.
What is built into the paraglider at all?
Basically it's
a polyamide, a nylon,
that's woven.
With this structure inside,
which is called ripstop.
And that's nothing other
than a weaving technique
that's done in warp and weft.
And this should actually prevent
that the cloth, when it once has a hole,
tears further.
These are small barriers in the cloth.
And these barriers ensure
that it doesn't tear further.
But you can also use very thin fabrics
that have a low weight
and are still very stable.
What's not so liked
is the diagonal load.
There there's rather a stretching in it.
However, you package them exactly so
that the load works as well as possible
on the cloth.
A heavy cloth,
here we're talking about a paraglider,
a standard paraglider,
that's not specially made for lightness,
we're at about 49 grams per square metre.
For comparison an A4 sheet
that you write on
has 80 grams per square metre.
But it can go much lighter,
namely with 17 grams.
There we're then in the
lightweight construction range,
where the manufacturer has made a wing construction
for hike-and-fly,
where you want light weight and little pack volume.
There we're still at 17 grams per square metre.
And this number, I'm sure,
will go down even further in the future,
because the techniques are ongoing,
researched and developed.
And naturally it's a concern
to have a fabric that's equally stable
and lighter than the whole.
What other materials do we have built in?
We have the wing itself,
we've now learned that
is a nylon ultimately.
You might also see in the cable cars
the ads up there, that we now also
build in PET bottles,
said with some paragliding exaggeration.
So ultimately just a plastic mix,
what happens in the paraglider area.
Also in the riser area
that's Dyneema, Technora.
We'll come to the lines
specifically right away.
We have the reserve parachute itself,
which is made of a nylon.
With the reserve parachute itself it's such that
it's actually the same cloth,
just woven much, much finer.
It's even much thinner there,
because of course the load on the reserve parachute is different.
Firstly, with the reserve parachute it's allowed to stretch.
It's not so important that it's fully form-stable,
because especially when there's a shock opening,
it's important that the whole thing stretches.
That starts with the line, but also with the cloth.
That's why there it matters less
if the cloth isn't quite so stable.
We'll also come to that briefly afterwards.
What we also have
is the aluminium carabiner.
We have on the one hand steel and aluminium on the market.
Opinions are divided here.
A long discussion,
who really is better.
Aluminium definitely has some disadvantages
for mechanical loads.
When we hold it on a stone,
aluminium certainly gets a dent faster
than with a steel carabiner.
However, these last very, very long and well.
And in general use
we say
we have to replace them about every five years.
The aluminium carabiner
in tests actually performs slightly better.
Namely, when the test was done,
where you have to allow a few millimetres of play
by opening and closing.
And a few thousand times over
ultimately the strength of the aluminium was better.
But we're talking here about strength,
which doesn't fall short
in normal use.
Right.
The paraglider has many lines.
That's
what's also decisive.
Because with this line you can on the one hand
do a lot, by choosing a material mix.
And we of course try
to get the best out of it,
so that every wing flies as long as possible
like it was newly built.
Because there with use there's some
difference. Certain lines
shrink a bit, certain lines stretch
a bit and that's why it's important
to have a clean mix there.
But we'll first start with the line material,
with the sheath.
Because every line that's sheathed,
I'll show that right now,
ultimately is the line inside itself
and the sheath around it.
The sheath is made for very simple reasons,
namely above all mechanical load.
That is, if I of course drag over a stone
or the lines rub against each other,
I have a protective layer over it here.
That works very well.
And I can cleanly separate them by colour.
Especially with school wings we often have
in the A area reds and then other colours,
so that from the start the beginner sees,
aha, this line I now have to
take in hand for that
and it's cleanly separated by colour.
That of course also has a small disadvantage,
namely that it makes the line much thicker
and thus the air drag
is of course also larger.
And exactly air drag is something
that you want to keep as low as possible.
That's why we ultimately also make lines
that aren't sheathed.
Which then look like this,
which have no sheath.
They also have the advantage of course
that we have very low weight,
little drag
and different materials are built up here.
We first take the brand name
of the Dyneema line.
That's the white line
we see here.
It's made of oriented polyethylene,
a plastic and it has
a good form.
Polyethylene is made from oriented plastic
and it has the big advantage,
that it has a very good weight-
to-strength ratio.
It's light and yet holds very, very much.
UV resistance is high,
ageing is also very good
and you can process it very well.
It has a super precise needle,
that's super sharp.
With this you can sew relatively well
and it's easy to work with.
It does have a small disadvantage,
that under load it also stretches.
You see that when checking,
when you have to measure the line.
And especially when not under load
it also shrinks a bit.
That means, when of course
the paraglider flies,
it has about
80% of the whole load
on the A and B riser group.
And at the back on the C or D riser group
are the remaining 20%.
That means of course,
if you build in this line
in the C and D area,
where it's hardly loaded,
there we're maybe still
at 300–500g per line,
then we tend to have
shrinkage there.
The other one that's on the market
is the aramid line, Technora, Kevlar.
The brand name has low stretch,
is very dimensionally stable along its length
and a high melting point.
It has a somewhat brownish colour.
And there it's quite clearly the big
disadvantage, that it's somewhat sensitive to kinking.
And especially when it's
kink-sensitive,
you have to pay good attention
to where you install it.
Because, if of course on the wing
there's a part where you say
it will now be quite strongly loaded,
then it's important
that it's insensitive there
to this kinking
or also above all
low stability.
That's why it's actually always a mix
between the aramid line
and the Dyneema line,
that you say, you put in the upper area
rather Dyneema
and in the lower rather the aramid line.
Simply, to have the mix in such a way
that you ultimately have it under control.
The UV load
is a small disadvantage.
That's why you often sheathe it.
Or if you don't sheathe it,
there's such a coating,
where you can also colour it a bit nowadays.
That's how colour separation takes place.
That's actually the art,
that you can coat the unsheathed line in such a way
that nevertheless the UV load
is very good and works.